yellen
sees several more months of rapid
inflation before easing worries about
housing impact this is a cnbc story
treasury secretary janet yellen
cautioned thursday that prices could
continue to rise for several more months
though she expects the recent start uh
start startling inflation run
to ease over time she added that she
worries about the problems
inflation could pose for lower income
families looking to buy homes at a time
where real estate values are surging the
consumer price index
which measures costs for a wide range of
items increased 5.4 percent in june the
fastest pace in 13 years
excluding food and energy the gauge rose
4.5
the fastest acceleration in 30 years
also housing prices in the nation's
largest cities climbed nearly 15 percent
of most recent measurements
though consumer survey points to
expectations of higher inflation ahead
yellen said she is encouraged by
market-based
measures that suggest prices will cool
over the long term so now
did you watch uh her being grilled by
kennedy yesterday i think it's senator
kennedy did you see did you see him
grilling oresa for like seven minutes
and 20 seconds
okay so he kept saying do you think
inflation is going to be higher by the
end of the year
she says if you look at it as a
12-monther
i don't think it's going to be that's
it's i'm going to ask you one more he
asked five different times she never
answered it
then he brought up the federal reserve
and said i don't want to comment on that
but she did
he says listen the feds are kind of
saying that they may and the market
reacted to it
meaning they're going to increase the
rates and they're not going to wait till
2023. well no it was a technical
adjustment that they have to make she
kept saying right technical adjustment
that they have to make
then i go and listen to powell when
powers powell says
you don't come up with permanent
responses to temporary situations
meaning this is just a temporary
inflation
that is here we don't need to
permanently you know temporarily raise
the rates
today to make up for inflation right i
mean that's kind of what they're talking
about right now
but yellen is definitely not saying that
this is going to go down anytime soon
she's not sitting there fighting it
she's saying no it's going to be here
but it's going to taper off and go away
right we're going to see what's going to
happen what are your thoughts on this
well i was on your podcast about a month
ago and i remember us talking about
janet yellen said that
inflation wasn't happening and joe biden
said no it's a one percent inflation
month over month it's one percent and
you're sitting here going what world are
they living in
what world are they living in they've
been lying to us the whole
time what would make you start thinking
they're telling the truth now
like if somebody trusts anything the
government's telling us at this point
i don't trust you like i have more faith
in conspiracy theorists than i have in
the government at this point i have more
faith
in those wet cardboard japanese beds
than i have in anything that comes out
of somebody in our
in our government's mouth doesn't it
seem like it's like the perfect storm
for high inflation and there sure is a
lot of talk about
not being inflation or there's going to
be inflation and
we're already starting to see it and you
said the market reflected it the other
day too it's coming there's no question
about it
i mean look at there's even a supply
chain problem that's still affected you
if you wanted to buy a new car
right now i don't know if you could i
mean it is that difficult to find a new
car right now and they're selling them
20 000 i have a friend who owns multiple
dealerships
20k over over asking price in california
people don't pay
and people will pay for it for some of
them and they'll have literally no new
car
inventory it's all the chips it totally
it's so that's what it is
so by the way here's here's uh what
look there's certain things that you
have to you almost need
side effects let me explain what i mean
by this if you eat 50 cheesecakes
in a week and you don't gain weight
there's something wrong
let me say that one more time yeah if
you eat 50 cheesecakes
what's the side effect the side effect
is happiness you're going to gain weight
right if you eat 20 hot dogs in the span
of an hour
what's probably going to happen you're
going to barf you're going to go
straight to the bathroom you're going to
barf
if you don't something's wrong with your
body let me let me say this one more
time
something is wrong with your body for
joey chestnut hard with this if
you take 20 shots of vodka and you don't
get drunk your body's broken
okay david that one's for you yeah so
here's the point
if you print six and a half trillion
dollars of money
okay you shut people down you put 50
million restaurants out of business 50
million employees out of business 10 000
restaurants out of business whatever the
number is
if you do that and you give people free
money to stay home
while you're giving them stimulus
if it doesn't break it's broken already
there's something wrong with the body
meaning when you print money
inflation goes up when you keep rates
low you can manipulate the market but
eventually you have to increase the
rates the rates are gonna go up or else
something is broken the math if three
times three is no longer nine
there is something wrong with the
calculator the calculator is the
government system that we have today
something has to go sure it's going to
happen so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you